I'm not gonna lie I'm getting a little
nervous oh my we have an injury here wow
there's so many beautiful people
everywhere okay so this week we are in
Miami Florida I'm on my way to juvy Oh
one of the best restaurants in South
Beach
but first let's make a quick stop to
pick up chef Sonny oh and a 20-17
rav4 hey what's up chef Sonny going home
how you doing good I really I'm doing
good nice to finally meet you
wait you too tell me a little bit about
yourself I was originally born in Korea
a Korean food is without that one life
from one of my favorite foods
I remember watching my mother singing
and cooking when I was a kid and she had
great knife skills singing cooking and
great knife skills that's quite the
Triple Threat can you tell us a little
bit about Juvia juvy has been off about
five years bringing together Union of
French ideas as well as Japanese and
proving influences what do we have in
store for our couples today we have a
local black grouper couples are gonna
have fun with some knife techniques and
it should be light and healthy
hello everyone my name is Carmen Rowe
and I am your host welcome to tasty date
night today we're here in South Beach to
watch as two couples with their
relationship and culinary skills through
the ultimate test
in a cooking showdown whoever impresses
our judge the most can look forward to a
romantic date night out here at Juvia
our first couple have been together for
17 years please help me welcome Brian
and Fatima we love all different kinds
of food so then we like to experiment
with new recipes all the time and I'm
Spanish and Cuban so I like to bring in
a little extra mix a little flair
a lot of times when we cook we cook
together I'm not gonna lie we like to
own the kitchen space totally there's
some things I just don't do well though
and she jumps in and takes care of all
those it would be awesome to win a date
night we're always working it's not
every day we get to go out to a nice
restaurant alone together right it
forced us to go forth you know it will
force us together to go our second
couple have only been together for one
year please help me welcome Nico and
Felicia we put together a lot on Sunday
so I kind of let him take over and I'd
like drink the wine and say like that
looks good and that looks great I don't
cook but I like to eat and I like to
cook and I'm Italian so I have to cook
you're nervous yeah I'm nervous about
the knives and the hot plates I think
I'm gonna ruin it for him I think we'll
do good we're a good team oh come on
okay well we wish you all the best of
luck in today's competition our chef and
judge for today Julia's own chef Sonny
Oh
how you doing Sonny what our couples
going to be cooking today local line
caught black grouper let's see if that
looks as good as it sounds all right
couples watch carefully because you are
going to cook this yummy pomegranate
Faro is one of the oldest grain I think
of it as like large brown rice
[Music]
looks like you're going to be using that
knife a lot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right couples you have 30 minutes to
cook and plate this dish without further
ado let's put 30 minutes on the clock
please let's get tasty no pressure guys
[Music]
horrible Thank You bacon
thanks Nika I got a bag a few longer
this banging I spent 10 minutes trying
to get home a granite seeds out of the
pomegranate
good job turn it up to ten oh my god
splash Sam got pomegranate juice all
over me sorry baby
Alina's that's good enough lunch brought
to you today by the good enough cooking
company alright Sonny so what is the
most important step to execute in order
to win today I think they need to get
that Cooper into the oven as quickly as
possible you know give it some color and
then get in because that's their
probably gonna take the most amount of
time how about doing everything right
however it's too late now great at this
table is a little higher I know I'm too
tall but hold on I'm not gonna lie I
didn't know that's how you get
pomegranate seeds out YUM all right
looks right watch it we're gonna burn
more front you're good at this right I'm
looking at it yeah it looks like you're
gonna burn it am I forgetting something
who put that
hmm let's go hot I focus on the fish on
the hot stuff
oh the hot stuff hot come on by coming
in hot
don't make some upset don't steal my
fish steamed fish I don't know which one
is doing everything you got this in
Japanese technique there's a style of
cutting it's not just about cutting the
product it's how you cut it the size of
it the cucumber the palm and the hearts
of palm want to remain to be about the
same size hoping I'll come myself
anytime
oh I kind of cut my thumb do you have a
band-aid my chance water if I recover
what a parent would cover it I did the
fish made the sauce all right it looks
like we are just about to approach the
20-minute mark there wrong way to peel
this I need to cut this pan hot enough
for the starkest interesting fact about
white asparagus is that's just grown in
the dark and that's why it's white
pressure zone great can you do the other
stuff to look at my phone
I can't you read it through when I miss
anything I don't think so we have to
read the directions famous last words
read the recipe if you wouldn't you have
to put salt in that I think I like diced
everything like pretty like nicely oh
did you put the timer on yeah that's for
the fish there are things that you can
be like I'm sure licious butter no wait
a bunch is cutting my finger Brian and
Fatima how are you two doing
I think we're right on track here I
think we're gonna put out a nice meal
I'll make the chef's proud Nico and
Felicia how are you two doing pretty
good I guess I mean I'm still alive
after cutting my thumb oh my dramatic
this is your mouth it is fine make some
noise for these couples job
oh my god we only have ten minutes ah
did you set it right you said it wrong
no you went this one is it moving
I don't think it's moving when I put
that on it you've went off frog is a
city they're not like oh you got thrown
that on ready
turn that off back bye Missy already
What's Up player
I like this though it's looking pretty
good a little bit of pepper on that
movie no I didn't I'm not allowed to do
the cooking time know what am i doing
I know dump it off nobody that's you for
I thought it was broken it'll break up
can you okay I need you to come back
tonight
should be a little chewy
hello man everyone
I'm just getting hungry you know I'm
slipped like six times in the kitchen
all right job two-minute warning
we're doing good I think we're almost
ready to go balls for the faro then we
put the grouper the visit the fish go on
top of it
if this leans on one side and then the
watercress goes in the hole seems like a
good ratio they're gonna make this look
sexy what through the photo first and
then we'll put this various kind of
light over like a beautiful video was
let's clean up the place and make them
look real nice I will how many's ficus
tree yeah mas rapido yeah dinner oh I
think I put one too many asparagus ten
nine eight seven six five four three two
one time time look at this good
sportsmanship going on here now turn to
your partner and give them a hug that
was so intense oh I see that little kiss
Felicia up first we have Brian and
Fatima
hey go SEF that was a little crazy that
30 minutes goes by a lot faster you do
you think it does it was a little
stressful I did a lot of dicing with all
my fingers still intact I'm gonna let
chef Sonny go ahead and take a first
bite here I'm just gonna copy what he
does I'll have you hold the mic all
right
well cooked nice balance thumb well this
is really good it's nice balance the
fish was cooked well
you can taste the butter in this other
fish the pomegranate cucumber and hearts
of palm seem like it balanced well with
the amount of father that's in it the
job thank you thank you well I'm pretty
convinced that we've won this I hope so
unless somebody switch the fish in the
oven when I couldn't see it I think we
made it look pretty I hope we did the
shop Josh this is yeah let's go ahead
and bring out Nikko and Felicia Bon
Appetit you're good the whirlwind still
like processing I just like tried to
stay out of his way I cut the cucumbers
I peeled the asparagus you know just
like things like a small child would do
I did and I think I did them like
adequately while chef Sonny is trying
some of this let me ask what did you to
struggle with I think making the time
work as far as the fish in the fodder on
boiling everything and putting on the
seasonings and that was the toughest
part done well done well balanced I
think the fish is cooked well good job
thank you
good I think we're gonna win you think
we're gonna win I think so we're gonna
win all right so that was really fun the
important thing about this dish is the
balance of everything coming together
the fish being cooked properly the
component elements coming together with
the proper amounts first couple the
officials cooked very well that's
something that stood out for me I think
their cuts were a little on the small
side Nico and Felicia's dish seemed like
it had a little bit more of a crust to
it so they gave a little more time to
sit there and crisp out on the pan
before they put in the oven
I like the cuts of the cucumber and
hearts of palm were bigger they seemed
to be a little more watercress there and
so it helped tie it together well do you
think that we have a definitive winner I
do all right well let's go ahead and
announce the winner welcome back
that was so fun both couples did
wonderful but let's get to it
drumroll please the winner of tasty date
night Miami is Nikola Felicia
congratulations to both couples good
feel good feel good now
there's a cool recipes yeah whatever
table Potter to put any event together
the fish was tasty it was tasty that was
funny
the whole experience was beautiful see
you at the holster game what look really
no I mean it was a great day great day
good competition
you didn't win but we had a great time
doing it we had a good plan going into
it we stuck to it and we played well off
each other yeah totally we're very proud
of ourselves thank you so much - Juvia
thank you to the city of Miami and the
amazing audience here this has been
tasty date night brought to you by
Toyota good job you guys that was
amazing amazing
[Applause]
[Music]